president Trump is a leader with more
followers than any political player in
modern history so therefore why would
you put yourself in a position where
you've got you know half the candidates
you know that are up there are not I
don't mean this in a bad way but they're
you know they have every right to run
but they're not serious candidates they
have no chance to win and if president
matter of fact I'm not sure that any of
the candidates that are that are out
there today if president Trump was just
to say hey see you guys later I'm gonna
go play golf in Florida
um have fun with your politics
my guess is that none of those
candidates would ultimately be the
Republican nominee so when you have the
votes sewed up there is no reason to
entertain
um you know kind of the chaotic uh
wannabe people that most likely would
not be the nominee anyway if president
Trump wasn't there